we all know Detroit's in trouble a
bankrupt city full of crumbling houses
abandoned factory buildings and a fast
dwindling population but while the
politicians unions and investors slug it
out in bankruptcy court and grasp for
their share of what little cash the city
has left ordinary citizens are left to
make do in a city with no functioning
government this is what happens when
people are left to their own devices
this is anarchy in Detroit the idea of
come up with is to take a little used
public park owned by the city of Detroit
called Belle Isle it's about a thousand
acres and apply for a change of status
from the state and from the federal
government and turn it into a
Commonwealth similar to the status
enjoyed by the north Northern Mariana
Islands or Puerto Rico rod Lockwood is a
real estate developer who's written a
book about his proposal to purchase
Belle Isle a 982 acre island in the
Detroit River Lockwood and his fellow
investors would buy the island for 1
billion dollars citizenship would then
go on sale for $300,000 a person but
Lockwood believes the low taxes and
friendly regulation would attract lots
of capital the benefits of bail out to
Detroit are that we would expect a
quarter trillion of capital would be
wrought onto the island this capital
would be then re spent and invested in
Detroit creating approximately more than
100,000 jobs Detroit would end up having
its own Singapore in its backyard the
chapter 9 bankruptcy that Wright's going
through will make the concept of Belle
Isle more feasible it puts the decision
on the disposition of the asset into the
hands of one person
there will be or already is significance
resistance to people who are saying
don't take our jewel of belle-isle we
are going to need to have support of
Detroiters I'm very optimistic that I
can overcome the entrenched political
forces because tray is a big problem
this is a big solution there are no
other solutions they've been put up with
regards to the opportunity here in
Detroit we have some elements that
actually put us at the front of the pack
so mentioned we're centrally located in
the in this country we have a
tremendously rich heritage we have some
of the best architecture great music
heritage we have cheap land good
availability of Labor here southeastern
Michigan has the greatest concentration
of engineers of any place in the world
right here this place is just waiting to
take off we just have to have better
rules
you